[Música]
en una noche de invierno en un auto de
alta gama al costado de una villa de
mataderos en la ciudad buenos aires
vidrios empañados gemidos y algunos
gritos se escuchaban desde adentro
patrulleros narcos merodeando por
alrededor allí estaba una mujer desnuda
arrodillada en el asiento trasero de
frente una tarta de jamón y queso recién
horneada apoyada sobre la luneta trasera
viviendo un eterno parto
multi orgásmicos
todo eso pasó en mi auto
y les cuento lo que fue llevarlo al
lavadero
esta experiencia su real pero verídica
fue todo lo opuesto al primer parto que
presencié en mi vida era mi primer día
de guardia en el hospital siendo
estudiante de partera y tenía tanta
emoción e ilusión imagínense iniciaba
mis prácticas iba a ser una parte de la
vida de las personas
y lo que viví en ese momento fue
impactante creí que la mujer iba a morir
desangrada y sentí miedo
pero por cómo se veía a los demás se
trataba de un típico parto estándar
normal sin complicaciones
la mujer estaba acostada boca arriba
sobre una camilla tenía las piernas
atadas colgando de unas tiras de cuero
le habían puesto en el brazo un goteo
endovenoso con medicación para acelerar
el parto sobre su cuerpo había una
persona apretándole el vientre como si
ella fuera un pomo de dentífrico le
cortaron la vagina yo era el primer
parto que veía y veía que salía bastante
sangre
mientras la mujer hacia fuerza les
separaban los genitales es como si el
dentista quisiera abrirte la boca al
tamaño de un pomelo
cuando la cabeza del bebé asomó quien
asistía el parto lo tomo lo tironeo
hasta que salió por completo
se lo veía azul y flácido colgando de
las manos de otra persona que lo
envolvieron a stella se lo acercó a la
madre para que lo hubiera un momento y
rápidamente se lo llevó para dejarlo en
observación
mientras la madre quedaba sola en un
pasillo agotada mirando el techo con los
brazos vacíos entre perdida y
desinteresadas el resto continuó con su
actividad como si nada hubiera pasado
yo que esperaba ese primer parto con
tanta ansiedad y tanto anhelo quedé
sintiéndome vacía y desorientada así
fueron pasando los años entre cientos de
nacimientos que llegaron a ser miles y
miles y miles sin exagerar les en los
que me surgían siempre las mismas
preguntas y era necesario usar
medicación para acelerar el parto era
correcto apretarle los vientres a las
mujeres y cortarles sus genitales
hubiera sido más fácil el parto con la
mujer estando sentada o agachada
buscando estas respuestas llegué a
canadá donde pasé algunas semanas junto
a colegas parteras viendo que las
mujeres que parían con ellas tenían la
libertad de probar y de cambiar
posiciones constantemente de sentarse
agacharse caminar estar acompañadas
siempre por alguien de sus afectos
abrazarla acariciar a sus parejas sin
ningún tipo de censura darse baños de
inmersión lo que les permitía transitar
y atravesar mucho mejor el dolor del
parto algunas incluso se ponían en
posición de cuatro patas
que era un poco medio raritos pero
entendí que seguimos siendo hembras
mamíferas aunque pidamos delivery o
usemos el whatsapp
este fue el primer contacto que yo tuve
a pelo compartos desinhibidos y estando
lejos de casa les voy a confesar a los
probé las drogas del parto natural que
me llevaron una irresistible adicción
sin retorno especialmente a la oxitocina
una poderosa sustancia que fabricamos en
nuestro cerebro y viaja por la sangre
presente en altísimas concentraciones
cuando nos abrazamos nos acariciamos
cuando compartimos momentos muy
placenteros con otros como jugar un
picadito de fútbol con amigos cuando
reímos a carcajadas limpias estando
solos o acompañados cuando nos damos
besos apasionados cuando paramos a un
bebé naturalmente cuando nacemos cuando
amamanta mos un bebé y especialmente
cuando nos echamos un buen polvo
pero las bondades de la oxitocina
exceden la sexualidad humana y al mundo
de la maternidad la oxitocina previene
la hipertensión arterial evita
accidentes cardiovasculares previene
enfermedades crónicas degenerativas y el
cáncer y sobre todas las cosas nos
empuja a sentir estados emocionales de
plenitud y de calma que nos dan la
confianza para entablar vínculos
afectivos libres de violencia como la
naturaleza tiene todo tan fríamente
calculado la oxitocina dispara la
fabricación de otras poderosas drogas
las betaendorfinas las betaendorfinas
son potentes calmantes y sedantes
similares al opio para contrarrestar el
tan temido fantasma del dolor
insoportable del parto
las betaendorfinas recompensan el
cansancio físico y el gran esfuerzo con
estados de mayor energías de bienestar y
de alegría que es lo que sentimos cuando
hacemos deporte y actividad física
ganándose el título de las hormonas de
la felicidad el placer y la
trascendencia la superación
en lo personal a mí la fisiología del
parto y el nacimiento me maravillan
porque tenemos todo ese potencial
biológico en nuestros cuerpos estas
sustancias se encadenan con otra hormona
que es la prolactina que durante el
trabajo de parto termina de madurar los
pulmones del bebé para que cuando nazca
respire sin dificultad
pero no sólo eso la prolactina induce en
la madre un estado de ternura hacia el
bebé y de tigresa hacia el entorno
guarda con acercarse a una hembra
mamífero
la prolactina así permite el cuidado y
la supervivencia de las crías pero
también protege a los niños de la
violencia familiar porque nos pone un
freno cuando ya estamos hartos de los
pibes y queremos acogotar los sobre el
final del parto entra en escena una
última hormona muy conocida que es la
adrenalina la adrenalina te coloca pum
para arriba atender esa te y lata las
pupilas te despeja te pone alerta
protege el corazón y el cerebro del bebé
en su pasaje por el canal de parto
inyecta a la mujer una fuerza descomunal
para que luche y se enfrente a la ardua
tarea de parir
este momento es sublime las mujeres
cobran una belleza y un poder
extraordinarios que algunos sobre todo a
quienes están desacostumbrados pueden
generarles bastante miedo recuerdo un
varón que me miraba con los ojos
desorbitados abiertos como el 2 de oro
viendo la expresión de su mujer pariendo
aterrorizado me miraba y pensaba que
ella iba a pegarle
para mí fue así yo me reía un poquito
por dentro
me generan tres gracia y ternura estas
hormonas se generan en tan altísimas
concentraciones hormonas del amor de la
felicidad de la ternura de la superación
de la euforia de la fuerza en tan altas
concentraciones que desbordan el cuerpo
de la mujer y del bebé y como un perro
ha mojado que se sacude impregnando a
todas las personas que están de cerca
compartiendo ese momento
para que se activen y se fabriquen estas
sustancias del amor de la ternura de los
gemidos de los orgasmos del destape de
de la cachondez son necesarios entornos
de privacidad y de intimidad donde la
mujer se sienta y todos no respetada
segura cuidada en confianza
esto es posible en un lugar más parecido
a un té lo que a un quirófano
pero más allá de esta explicación
entretenida científica lógica
seguramente haya algunos algunas de
ustedes que crean profundamente que el
parto es un evento riesgoso
de hecho el promedio nacional necesarias
así se los confirmaría
según registros recientes de la
organización mundial de la salud casi 7
de cada 10 mujeres son operadas en el
sistema médico privado en nuestro país
terribles nos hacen creer que la
naturaleza está basada en nosotros y
necesitamos de la asistencia médica en
los partos sin embargo la organización
mundial de la salud recomienda una tasa
de cesáreas de entre el 10 y el 15 por
ciento y afirma que cuando
la tasa necesarias supera
ese 10%
aumenta la mortalidad de mujeres y de
bebés
bueno esta discordancia nos deja un poco
que pensar
entonces
qué es lo que causa
esta epidemia reconocida en nuestro país
de cesáreas
uno de los motivos es el uso
indiscriminado de goteos endovenosos
con oxitocina artificial que si bien
copia algunos efectos de la oxitocina
natural
carece de la inteligencia para proteger
a la mujer y al bebé durante el proceso
porque porque impide que se active el
cóctel de las otras hormonas que son
protectoras durante el proceso del parto
y el nacimiento
hace algunas décadas se llevaron a cabo
varios estudios que mostraron que el uso
excesivo de procedimientos y de rutinas
médicas en los partos que agrede afecta
hostil y violentamente el desarrollo
natural
se asocia a mayores índices de
delincuencia de drogadependencia
suicidios trastornos del espectro
autista y violencia en la sociedad
lo que nos toca a todos directa o
indirectamente
además de poner en riesgo la vida de
madres mujeres bebés o incluso a
provocarles la muerte o dejarles
secuelas y discapacidades para el resto
de su vida
tiempo atrás me contactó una mujer
embarazada que ya tenía dos hijos
nacidos por cesárea el menor de ellos
había desarrollado autismo
investigando acerca de esta condición
ella supo que se trataba de una
predisposición genética que según
algunos estudios resulta en bajas
concentraciones bajos niveles de
oxitocina en sangre y que la forma de
nacer para estas personas podría ser un
factor clave además de otras múltiples
causas para activar o silenciar estos
genes y un parto que permite y estimula
la fabricación espontánea de oxitocina
en altísimas concentraciones en la madre
y en el bebé y además protege y permite
después del nacimiento un contacto
inmediato madre e hijo piel con piel por
un tiempo prolongado favorecería un
desarrollo neurológico normal y podría
anular una de las potenciales causas
contar con esta información fue lo que a
ella la determinó para elegir un parto
vaginal después de dos cesáreas sin
intervenciones para
a su tercer hijo
otro ejemplo es el uso de narcóticos
artificiales también derivados del opio
similares a las betaendorfinas como la
meperidina o la nueva ina que facilita y
predispone en las personas el desarrollo
a la drogadependencia
entonces estos químicos artificiales o
naturales dejan huellas
2 ustedes todos nosotros que el sistema
químico elegimos activar y alimentar
desde el inicio mismo de la vida
al sistema del miedo del dolor de la
violencia de la desconfianza de la
atención o al sistema del amor de la
cachondez del abrazo del éxtasis de la
calma de la felicidad
la manera en cómo nacemos importa porque
la química del parto nos va a acompañar
siempre
michel odent un médico francés cartero y
anestesista autor de muchísimos libros
traducidos a decenas de idiomas que ha
escrito sobre el cóctel de las hormonas
del amor las funciones de los orgasmos
la importancia de las parteras el daño
de los plásticos y las drogas usadas en
los partos y el impacto en la sociedad y
a quién les recomiendo que lean nos dice
que para cambiar al mundo primero hay
que cambiar la forma de nacer
tal vez pienses que nada puedes hacer
con esta información pero si podés
cambiar la forma de nacer de alguien y
eso va a repercutir en su vida y en
todos nosotros como sociedad
parir y nacer naturalmente valen la pena
y el esfuerzo y las intervenciones de
interferencias médicas deberían estar
estrictamente justificadas como nacemos
en el presente será la plataforma para
nuestro futuro
[Aplausos]
[Música]